I would advise anyone including myself
that any moment you are you understand
your life is good then everything that
led up to it was worthwhile and the
reason I say that is not that I haven't
laid mistake I'd made some glorious
mistakes and I've suffered in the life
for those mistakes but I'm sitting here
talking to you this morning and my world
I am too concerned with the product the
problems that envelop us everywhere but
in my personal world I couldn't be
happier I have six kids they to like me
thoroughly and they are all very close
with one another our family get together
so the best thing going in my life so I
figure if i can say that at this moment
feel that at this moment i wouldn't
change anything that got me here you
know all the mistakes all of the drama
all of the that went on earlier
that was so much of which i was
responsible for if if the moment you're
at is a great moment and you're happy
for who you are at this moment and
everything that got you here is
worthwhile because it's all gone that's
yesterday the 22 of most important words
i think are over and next when something
is over it is over and we're all on to
next and the hammock in the middle
between those two words is what i think
is meant by truly living in the moment
you know when i get it from this
interview as great as it was it's over
there ain't anything i can do if i wish
to fix or change or i've done it next
I think being invested in next and not
the past is best